Boy in blue: Our teacher
would have the textbook
up on the overhead projector
so we could all see it.
Boy in gray: We kind of just sat there
and we did like different sections.
Girl in green: i'm a daydreamer
so I kind of zone out sometimes.
Boy in blue: Read the lesson
and then we would get homework.
Girl in green: There's always
at the end of each section.
Boy in blue: Yeah,
that's how it was before.
Girl in green: I used to
get like B's all the time
but since Khan Academy it's brought
me up to an A so that was really cool.
Girl in pink: In a way I use Khan
Academy is I do the exercises
and it really helps me
improve my Math skills,
and I watch the videos if I'm having
trouble with some of the exercises,
and then I'm able to get a streak of 10.
Boy with eyeglass: She can see what you're
doing and so if you're messing around
she'll tell you to just
do these set of problems.
If you're really struggling with
it she'll help you out with it,
if you just don't get what the
video is trying to ask you.
Girl in pink: I like how it's
different than the Math book
when everyone's doing pretty
much the same level of things,
and if you're like higher
then it's boring for them.
If they're like lower they're
not exactly understanding it.
Girl in pink: I used to be afraid to
like tell her what I'm struggling on
and now that she can see how
we're doing on the Khan Academy
it helps me feel more
comfortable talking to her
about what I'm having trouble with.
Boy in blue: You get to move
at your own pace with it
because there are all sorts
of challenging exercises
and there are easy exercises.
Girl in pink: It's really fun
because you can try to get badges
and you can challenge yourself
and do different kinds of Math.
Boy in black: There's meteor
badge, moon badge, earth badge,
sun badge, and black hole badge.
Girl in green: I didn't really remember
exponents even though I did it once.
I didn't remember it very much
and then I watched the video
and now I know exponents, really easy.
Boy in blue: The guy who makes them,
Sal, he teaches the subject really well.
Girl in pink: It's like he's
probably like writing on the computer
because it shows this little mouse
and he talks into the microphone.
He explains all the subjects in a way,
it just makes it really easy to learn.
Boy in black: Well my parents
think it's really cool,
they think it's a great idea
that we're doing this site.
The good thing is we don't have
to be at school to learn Math.
We can just be at home on our
computers basically doing it.
Girl in pink: Like if it's a
rainy day you can just do it
and then you can energy
points and get badges.
Boy in blue: I really like it when I
finish one of the really hard ones.
Boy with eyeglass: It's a tool for life.
Everybody needs to know how
to do certain things in Math,
not just if you're going to be
like an astronomist you
have to know everything.
Boy in gray: One night I was
just working on this lesson
and I just couldn't finish it.
My Dad said you can't play with your
friends until you finish that lesson.
Then i finally finished it because I
watched the video and I really learned it.